wir schreiben das jahr 2030 das programm
war erfolgreich und wir haben eine erste
basis auf dem mond errichtet der
weltraumtourismus beginnt fahrt
aufzunehmen und immer mehr menschen
zieht es ins weltall
doch der größte schritt der menschheit
steht noch bevor die reise zum mars
das luna gateway ist bereit um reisen
bis zum roten planeten und darüber
hinaus zu ermöglichen
spacex hat die finale version ihres
stars chips fertiggestellt und die
astronautinnen und astronauten der nasa
stehen in den startlöchern
als erste menschen der geschichte zu
einem anderen planeten zu fliegen
aber wie genau bereitet uns das
rettungsprogramm denn jetzt noch mal auf
dem mars vor
wieso überhaupt der mars und was bringt
uns das alles eigentlich hier auf der
erde
all diese fragen beantworten wir jetzt
im dritten und letzten teil unserer art
[Musik]
bevor wir mit dem eigentlichen video
anfang habe ich eine ankündigung zu
machen und zwar haben wir nun endlich
das gemacht was viele von euch schon
seit jahren wollten nämlich doktor
watson merge
[Musik]
das hier ist das erste motiv das an den
start geht der mars-rover presse wir uns
denn gerade auf dem mars herum fährt und
dort nach zeichen von leben sucht und
zwar unter anderem mit diesen sensoren
und gerätschaften hier
es gibt shirts und es gibt all dies und
das allerwichtigste natürlich machen wir
es richtig fair für alle beteiligten und
nachhaltig alle in der kette von der bio
baumwollplantage über die näherei bis
zum druck werden fair bezahlt und
bekommen ganz transparent das hier pro
shirt und das hier poly und auch was wir
an dem merger verdienen könnt ihr euch
hier ansehen
das geld geht übrigens direkt hier
wieder in mehr und bessere videos für
euch und das ganze läuft über fashion
dice wo auch schon joseph the change
männer alter nativ oder auch alexy weg
sie sind und die achten wirklich darauf
dass alles super korrekt ist und fair
gehandelt ist und ja wenn man es richtig
macht dann kostet ein t shirt ebenso
viel wie die fast fashion industrie ihre
klamotten so günstig herstellen kann
haben wir hier in diesem video schon mal
erklärt deswegen könnt ihr jetzt auch
erstmal nur shirts und hoodies
vorbestellen das ganz wichtig die
bekommt ihr noch nicht sofort
zugeschickt dann wenn die vorbestellung
phase vorbei ist wissen wir ganz genau
wie viele exemplare wir produzieren
müssen und auf diese art und weise wird
nichts über produziert was dann irgendwo
rum gelagert werden muss oder sogar
wieder weggeschmissen wird also schaut
mal auf doktor watson punkt shop da
findet ihr alle wichtigen infos und
könnte auch direkt bestellen
und ich bin ja schon mega gespannt wie
das jetzt bei euch ankommt was haltet
ihr von dem design gehört zu merck gerne
unten in die kommentare findet jetzt
cool finde jetzt nicht so cool und
welche motive und designs ihr euch noch
vorstellen könnt für einen womöglich ein
zweiter drop irgendwann mal ja also
schreibt mir ein
vielen dank und ich hoffe euch gefällt
[Musik]
was genau bringt es uns hier auf der
erde wenn ein mensch einen anderen
planeten betritt an sicher erstmal nicht
viel aber was ihn dahin gebracht hat und
was er dann da macht das bringt uns
schon deutlich mehr
die nasa hat hier ein ziemlich schönes
motto erkundung ermöglicht wissenschaft
und wissenschaft ermöglicht erkundung
schon auf der iss wurden unzählige
experimente von wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern durchgeführt die
menschen hier auf der erde das leben
gerettet haben
zum beispiel wurden ultraschallgeräte
telemedizin und generell technologie die
man aus der ferne steuern kann alle für
die iss entwickelt und dort getestet
wenn auf dem mars etwas schief geht dann
kann man astronauten nicht einfach
zurück zur erde fliegen um sich hier zu
behandeln
man braucht also technologie die vor ort
und ohne viel drumherum funktioniert und
sogar aus der ferne gesteuert werden
kann
das ist auch hier auf der erde der fall
wenn es zum beispiel eine katastrophe
gegeben hat oder man in abgelegene
gebiete kommen muss dann können
medizinische hilfskräfte zum beispiel
auf mobile ultraschallgeräte
zurückgreifen
patienten können vor ort untersucht
werden und ein arzt kilometer weit
entfernt kann entscheidungen treffen die
leben retten
ein weiterer wichtiger punkt ist wasser
ob in der sahara oder auf einem fernen
planeten wasser ist kostbar und
trinkwasser umso mehr auf der iss
entwickelte wasseraufbereitungs geräte
wie das environmental control and life
support system kommen in vielen ländern
zum einsatz wo sie menschen zugang zu
sauberem trinkwasser ermöglichen und in
naher zukunft werden diese geräte das
auch auf dem mars tun
computertomografie wärmedämmung und
sogar simons kameras die in jedem
smartphone stecken das sind alles
erfindungen die es nur dank der
raumfahrt gibt die nasa hat eine über
200 seiten langes buch herausgebracht
dass einige der errungenschaften der
internationalen raumstation auflistet
ich habe schon mal verlinkt 200 seiten
und das ist nur die iss und wer weiß was
wir noch alles erfinden entdecken und
lernen werden wenn wir erst einmal zum
mars fliegen darüber hinaus werden wir
auch eine multi planetare spezies das
hauptziel des mars rover providence ist
die suche nach leben oder zumindest dem
was davon übrig geblieben ist
mikroskopische überreste von pflanzen
oder bakterien vielleicht lernen wir so
auch mehr über unsere ursprünge und
unsere zukunft was ist mit dem leben auf
dem mars passiert und könnte uns dieses
schicksal vielleicht auch einmal ereilen
wie können wir das verhindern
alles fragen die uns der mars
hoffentlich beantworten kann
okay aber wie genau wollen wir denn
jetzt den mars besiedeln
wir schauen uns jetzt erstmal die
aktuellen pläne der nasa an
ja uns ist bewusst dass space exter
eigene pläne hat die firma um ihre maske
hat ja das sehr ambitionierte ziel
menschen schon 2026 zum roten planeten
zu schicken was aber ursprünglich mal
2024 stattfinden sollte diese video hier
die artemis reihe hat allerdings die
nasa und ihre pläne im fokus weshalb
spacex thema für ein eigenes video ist
kurz vor der veröffentlichung unseres
zweiten teils dieser reihe hier kamen
auch die nachricht dass space extrem
luna länder für artemis drei bauen soll
die nasa und space ex werden also
vermutlich auch bei den mars missionen
zusammen arbeiten aktuell ist zu diesen
plänen aber noch nicht viel bekannt
redaktionsschluss ist heute der zweite
juni 2021 daher konzentrieren wir uns
jetzt erstmal auf die pläne der nasa
stellt euch vor ihr befindet euch in den
2030er jahren der grundstein für eine
mondbasis wurde gelegt und mehrere
erfolgreiche artemis missionen liegen
bereits hinter uns das gateway ist
fertig und macht reisen bis zum mars und
sogar darüber hinaus möglich zu diesem
zeitpunkt müssten die ersten proben vom
mars die der provence bohrer entnommen
hat auf der erde angekommen sein
wie genau das wird gerade von der esa
erforscht denn den mars boden
untersuchen zu können bevor wir menschen
dorthin schicken wäre ein riesiger
vorteil wir könnten experimente auf der
erde durchführen und zukünftige
astronautinnen und astronauten besser
darauf vorbereiten
als nächstes will die nasa dann alle
wichtigen ausrüstungsgegenstände und
technologien die die marsianer brauchen
vorab auf dem mars platzieren
dazu gehören maschinen die sauerstoff
und treibstoff aus der atmosphäre
extrahieren können roboter bauteile für
ein habitat fahrzeuge und viele weitere
wissenschaftliche geräte die nasa
versucht hier eine ehrt unabhängige
mission vorzubereiten denn die mars
mission wird im schlimmsten fall drei
jahre dauern so lange muss die erste
crew überleben ohne im notfall zur erde
zurückkehren zu können wenn irgendetwas
schief geht irgendetwas auch noch eine
kleinigkeit muss improvisiert werden
sonst war's das quad mail lässt grüßen
denn ein flug zum mars dauert circa
sieben monate wenn mars und erde perfekt
zueinander stehen
sonst dauert es sogar noch länger und
diese optimale planeten konstellation
ergibt sich nur alle 26 monate
die nasa muss sich also relativ sicher
sein dass sie eine crew für mindestens
zwei jahre am leben halten kann extrem
wichtig hierfür ist natürlich essen
schon auf der iss wurde mit pflanzen
experimentiert die auch auf der
mondoberfläche wachsen könnten wie zum
beispiel radieschen
man kann natürlich nahrung vorab auf dem
mars platzieren aber die reicht nicht
für zwei jahre
die forscherinnen und forscher müssen
also selber hand anlegen und auch hier
mag rodney lässt grüßen schlafen muss
die crew ebenfalls für eine basis auf
dem mars gibt es bereits diverse
konzepte zum beispiel ziemlich coole in
berge hineingebaut häuser um die
insassen vor der strahlung zu schützen
aber das ist natürlich auf der ersten
mission ziemlich unrealistisch
als einen außenposten wird es hier
wahrscheinlich nicht geben die nasa
spricht auch davon die astronautinnen
und astronauten zwischen eine art
station im orbit dem raumschiff und
einem habitat auf dem mars pendeln zu
lassen
so können sie je nach situation umziehen
der aufenthalt auf der oberfläche des
mars selber wird also erstmal nicht
besonders lange sein
aktuell geht die nasa hier von gerade
mal 30 tagen aus insbesondere da das
habitat ja erstmal gebaut werden muss
[Musik]
schaffen die weltraum pioniere es die
zwei jahre zu überleben und zur erde
zurückzukehren dann werden wir ein
besseres verständnis für leben in
unserem universum und auch viele neue
forschungs grundlagen haben
die so gewonnenen erkenntnisse werden
dann wieder neue erkundungsmission
unmöglich machen die wir uns jetzt noch
gar nicht vorstellen können
wenn der grundstein für die besiedlung
des mars gelegt ist dann geht es aber
erst richtig los das habitat wird stück
für stück ausgebaut und alle 26 monate
können menschen zum mars geschickt
werden
aktuell gibt es schon konzepte für ganze
städte auf dem mars nie was ich hier ist
eines dieser konzepte die stadt soll bis
zu 250.000 einwohner beherbergen können
und größtenteils in felsen gebaut werden
wo die marsianer wohnen sollen auch wenn
mit ressourcen von der erde begonnen
wird soll die stadt ab einer gewissen
größe nur durch materialien vermaß
weiter ausgebaut werden und so
irgendwann zur autonomie übergehen
aber all das steht natürlich noch in den
sternen also lassen wir mal zusammen
nach erfolgreichem abschluss des atems
programms und mit mehreren
vorbereitenden missionen zum mars hinter
uns wird im nächsten jahrzehnt der erste
mensch den mars betreten
unser hauptziel wird es sein die
geschichte des mars zu entschlüsseln und
so mehr über unseren planeten zu lernen
auf der zwei bis dreijährigen missionen
muss dimas crew nicht nur für einige
zeit auf dem planeten überleben sondern
auch unzählige experimente durchführen
und der einsamkeit des alls trotzen
dabei werden sie auf die hilfe von
technologien angewiesen sein die zuvor
auf dem mond getest wird und extra für
sie weiterentwickelt wurden
darüber hinaus müssen sie den grundstein
für eine erste
maas basis setzen unter diesen pionieren
werden menschen sein die jetzt gerade
erst in wahrscheinlich unserem alter
sind und solche videos hier schauen denn
die reise zum mars wird auch eine ganz
neue generation von astronautinnen und
astronauten inspirieren weiterzudenken
zu den sternen zu schauen und vielleicht
sich zu fragen was es dort draußen noch
alles und falls ihr so jemand seit und
in 10 oder 20 jahren zum mars fliegen
wollt dann schaut euch doch unser video
wie werde ich astronaut an denn wenn du
dein leben jetzt in die richtige bahn
längst könntest du tatsächlich
irgendwann selber auf dem mars stehen es
ist nicht unmöglich
[Musik]
der flug zum mars wird der nächste große
schritt der menschheitsgeschichte und
auch unser leben hier auf der erde
voranbringen
manche menschen sind sogar der meinung
wir müssen zum mars um die spezies zu
schützen wenn wir keine multi planetare
spezies werden werden wir irgendwann auf
der erde ausgelöscht sagte maas klingt
vielleicht sehr extrem aber er sieht es
wirklich als notwendig an dass die
menschheit quasi ein backup bekommt war
sie eine zweite festplatte so dass eine
von beiden fällen kann und die
menschheit trotzdem überlebt wie der
plan von spacex aussehen soll haben wir
in diesem video hier bewusst ausgelassen
falls ihr dazu auf ein eigenes video
sehen wollt schreibt mir das gerne unten
in die kommentare
und ansonsten hoffe ich das euch diese
artemis reiche gefallen hat und jetzt
hab ich noch eine frage sollten wir
häufiger so größere serien mit mehreren
videos machen zu einem thema oder doch
lieber ein thema pro video
ich habe das gefühl dass unsere videos
in letzter zeit immer länger und immer
ausführlicher werden
und manchmal wird es besser denke ich
dass man so ein thema in zwei teile oder
in drei teile aufgeteilt damit man
wirklich zeit hat in die details
einzugehen schreibt mir das gerne mal in
die kommentare was ihr davon haltet
ansonsten vielleicht fürs zuschauen und
wie immer bleibt neugierig